pomp und gloria stuck und ornamente das
ist barock vanitas pest und krieg
auch das ist barock diese widersprüche
des barock die diese epoche so china und
machen und die sich im lebensgefühl des
carpe diem verdichten diskutiere ich
heute in der sternstunde philosophie und
zwar mit dem philosophen gouna hinrichs
mit dem barock musiker peter kennen und
mit dem schauspieler anatole taubman
denn viele von ihnen vermutlich vor
allem aus dem james bond film ein
quantum trost kennen der aber auch
barock kann
anatole taubman die sind mitten in den
dreharbeiten zur fernsehserie werk sei
die mit dem stolzen budget von 25
millionen euro
eine der teuersten produktionen ihres
genres sein wird verraten sie uns ein
paar details dieser glamourösen gering
es ist anscheinend die teuerste
fernsehserie türkisch in der
fernsehgeschichte europas ja das wird
von canal plus finanziert in englischer
sprache und beschreibt in der ersten
staffel 16
das jahr 16 67 wo ludwig der vierzehnte
sich mehr oder weniger von seiner mutter
losgelöst hat von all seinen mehr oder
weniger zum absoluten monarch wurde und
auch dann gesagt hat werk sei hier will
ich sein
alle noblen alle adligen hier zitiere
aus
ja das war auch der beginn von der der
anfang von der lagonda enquete vor allen
adligen die rechte genommen hat eine
spiel spielen die ich also ich kann ich
kann ihnen nur sagen die danach in
meiner figur der heißt montur was der
genau macht der macht viel wasser genau
macht das ansehen
das kommt nächsten herz kommt das
weltweit wird das ausgestrahlte wir
werden noch mehr machen wahrscheinlich
darauf zurückkommen wie das auch ist ein
barock figur zu verkörpern geht erkennen
sie sind ein gefragter countertenor sie
sind barockmusiker haben sich dieser
epoche geradezu verschrieben was
lebensjahr barock ich habe da gibt es
viele dinge die die üppigkeit dass die
vielseitigkeit die gegensätze all das
liebe ich sehr in nicht nur in der musik
sondern auch in meinem leben
die gegensätze die haben wir hier auch
habe ich nachgebildet im stile eines
stilllebens von caravaggio obst früchte
eigentlich in luxus in form dieses roten
teenie-star heutiges leben aber auch
vanitas auf der anderen seite die
vergänglichkeit der tod der lauert nach
hinrich sind professor für philosophie
an der universität basel finden sich
diese gegensätze auch im denken dieser
zeit im denken ja in der philosophie ist
das etwas schwieriger
also insbesondere die von ihnen
angesprochene vanitas vergänglichkeit
auf der einen seite das pflücke den tag
das carpe diem auf der anderen seite das
sind glaube ich eher dinge die in
literatur vielleicht den kunst eine
größere rolle spielen der philosophie
sich weniger niedergeschlagen hat ich
besitze keinen grund das weiß ich gar
nicht genau ob es dafür einen grund gibt
und die philosophie beschäftigt sich
eher mit so etwas wie dem absolutismus
in der politischen philosophie oder mit
konstruktionen des welt zusammenhangs in
der theoretischen philosophie in der
metaphysik
das sind deren fragen und eben auch mit
den effekten also mit dem wie wir als
menschen in einer solchen welt leben
können auch darauf waren wir dann später
noch zurückkommen
beginnen wir wahr wenn ihr an den barock
denken damit was eigentlich am
naheliegendsten ist die alle kennen
barockkirchen die maler die architekten
haben in dieser zeit ja alles gegeben um
dick aufzutragen im bild sehen wir die
klosterkirche einsiedeln auch eine
innenansicht barock und schwülstig pomp
und gloria ich am anfang gesagt habe
anna tauben und auch peter kennen sie
beide sind hier zur schule gegangen ich
bin ja sie waren ja glaube ich nicht
klappen weil wir nicht aber ich wusste
nicht dass das sie her kenne auch in
einsiedeln zur schule mussten sie noch
eine kutte tragen habe ich nicht aber
beim papst besuchte er da in der zeit
stattfand habe ich dann eine gute
angezogen das war schon toll mal so
herumzulaufen so pater kassian das nicht
wahr sein eigenes andere eltern
ich wusste ich nicht also für mich löst
das einsiedeln wenn sie mich so fragen
einfach und auch diese kirche heimat
geborgenheit sicherheit aus für mich war
einzigen eine wunderschöne sehr sehr
prägende zeit ja und ich finde auch die
kirche wunderschön
ich habe mich damals als teenager wenig
mit kirche songs beschäftigt ich hatte
andere probleme aber das löst bei mir
mein herz macht putzen ein krieg sagt
wohl alles nein nein
also ich gehe immer wieder gerne nach
einzigen auch in der kirche gerade eben
weil die so unglaublich barock ist in
jeder hinsicht und ob ich mich dann
geborgen fühlen vielleicht etwas anderes
habe ich konnte auch nach der zeit in
der schule in einzigen auch verschiedene
konzerte dort aufführen und das ist dann
auch die verbindung mit diesem raum mit
der musik ist schon einmalig und gerade
dieser raum in einzelne so diese größe
auch hat und diese vielseitigkeit das
ist ganz toll für mich auch immer wieder
komme ich gerne zurück
kennen sie entschuldigung können sie an
sich war nicht unbedingt sehen
aber ja es ist schon sehr beeindruckend
auch die barocke musik die feiert ja
gott auch die ist pompös also das feiern
von gott verspielt eine ganz ganz große
rolle in der barocken musik hören wir
uns ein beispiel an nämlich den beginn
des magnificat von johann sebastian bach
[Musik]
eine erhabenheit 1 1
ein sinnliches fest was man hier hört
dass sondergleichen gekoppelt mit
eigentlich ein kompositionsprinzipien
kontrapunktik das ist einfach einmalig
das ist ja klar es ist auch ein super
beispiel was bach auch immer gesagt hat
dass die musik zu ihre gottes sein muss
und sein soll und auch zur re creation
des gemüts dazu sein soll und das ist
ein paradebeispiel für das ist diese
freude die da herrscht also diese
lobpreisung marias zur weihnachtszeit
geschrieben ist toll da kommen ja auch
pauken vor es kommen bläser vor sind die
streicher und typisch für den barock ist
er auch die sogenannte polyphonie das
eben unabhängige melodien voneinander
ihren weg suchen einander ergänzender
umschlingen und nicht mehr eine melodie
die dann einfach ein bisschen begleitung
dazu kriegt ja was leichter zu
präzisieren dass ja diese kontrapunktik
diese hessischen kontrapunkte ja das ist
polyphonie komplex dargestellt sich eine
stimme sind nur eine oberstimme und ein
bagger container sondern sind mehrere
stimmt die komplex ineinander verlaufen
und da gibt es die schiene vom mit eben
fuge oder andere teile zu dem wir
vielleicht später noch dazu kommen und
dann die monate die eigentlich im
gegensatz darstellt die weniger komplex
komponiert ist und aber diese
komplexität dieses polyphonie das ist ja
schon eine eine kompositionsprinzipien
zeit und gerade johann sebastian bach
hat es einfach noch weiter gezogen und
habe das perfektioniert in dem sinne
aber die bewegung war natürlich dann
auch ineinander andere richtung gerade
in der oper die man von dieser
komplexität wegging mich persönlich
ergreift barocke musik immer noch
unglaublich viel etwas und großartigste
was es gibt wie geht es irgendwie mögen
die barocke musik
ich finde privat würde ich es nicht
hören
für den beruf finde ich es auch göttlich
ein wenig für den beruf auf
hintergrundmusik wir werfen wenn man
oder jetzt für werk sei wenn ich nie
figur versucht zu bewohnen oder zu
begreifen oder eine zeit versucht zu
begreifen oder zu verstehen dann bediene
ich mich natürlich auch da muss sie
verschiedenen quellen aber auch der
musik und dann ist das eine wunderschöne
inspiration also die mehrstimmige musik
also den kontrapunktik und die
polyphonie das ist auch etwas was mich
sehr anspricht
ich glaube das hängt damit zusammen dass
es auch eine besonders rationale musik
sein kann nicht weil wir da sein muss
weil die stimmen zusammen passen müssen
und gleichzeitig aber eben auch einen
stark eine starke ausdrucksvolle musik
ist sie hat auch manchmal etwas witziges
nicht also gerade jetzt im magnificat am
ende wenn er wenn das dann heißt sie
gute rating brink ipo wie es war am
anfang jetzt sind immer da
dann kommt die anfängliche musik wieder
ja das ist ein kleines augenzwinkern
was macht sich da erlaubt nicht dass
gibt es darin auch andere form der
barockmusik liegen mir nicht so sehr
also das große gegenmodell zu dieser
mehrstimmigen musik ist ja oftmals das
italienische konzert auch sehr beliebt
waren die reval tischen konzerte aber
damit kann nicht selber nicht so viel
anfangen obwohl ich es als form zu
schätzen weiß wenn über die philosophie
sprechen dann ist ja sehr sehr auffällig
dass in keiner philosophiegeschichte
zumindest in keiner mehr bekannten der
barock aus epoche vorkommt leider ist
das so stark in die philosophie als das
ist ein problem er ist auch ein problem
für uns nicht also wenn wir über die
philosophie im zeitalter des barock
sprechen dann sprechen wir über eine
philosophie von der nicht ganz gleich ob
sie selber barock ist oder etwas anderes
es gibt eine ausnahme die ich direkt
erwähnen will ende des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts hatte die löw versucht das
barocke denken auf einen begriff zu
bringen er ist der einzige und hat das
versucht in bezug auf leibnitz und der
titel seines buches
laut viply die falte ein verrückter
titel und damit gemeint ist dass das
barocke denken versucht das an leibnitz
zu zeigen
ein denken ist dass sich in entfaltungen
und den einst haltungen bewegt wir haben
da vorher noch gemeinsamen papier
gefahren ein kleines kleines hilfsmittel
schön gemacht also wie dieses papier
eingeschaltet ist und sich aushalten
lässt
so stellt sich laut dieser these das
barocke denken das gesamte universum vor
das gesamte universum ist sozusagen ein
einziger faltenwurf wenn man so möchte
und es geht darum die aus haltungen und
die entfaltung dieses denkens zu
begreifen
vielleicht können wir das noch mal hier
an der kirche in einsiedeln die wir eben
gesehen haben zeigen es gibt also die
fassade die nach außen geht und dann
gibt es ein inneres und die these von
deleuze ist auch in der architektur ist
das zu begreifen als eine entfaltung
eines einzelnen nach innen und nach
außen und das einzelne ist nicht noch
mal etwas drüber stehen das sondern
zeigt sich in solchen falten
verhältnissen kann man darüber
nachdenken ob das stimmt oder nicht er
kennt auch ein bisschen spannender was
ihr kompliziert also ich muss jetzt erst
gleich mal rückfragen natürlich hat eine
barocke kirche eine fassade und ein
inder leben aber es hat ja jedes haus
der hat ja auch ein themen
buddhistisches kloster das ist richtig
also die kunst es gibt eine
kunsthistorische bedeutung auf die idee
sich der bezieht und diese
kunsthistorische bedeutung sagt dass die
fassade absolut außen ist und die
innenräume geschlossene absolut
geschlossene enorm es gibt also keine
durchdringung von zb sieht man von außen
nicht die konstruktion soll man auch
nicht sehen die sie in vorhanden ist
sondern die fassade geht meist nur nach
außen und die räume sind nur geschlossen
wir haben zb nichts prunkvolle bunte
fassaden sondern nur der innenraum zeigt
dieses bunte punkt fallen
das kann man so auch nicht sagen die
fassade ist ja durchaus auch sehr
prunkvoll nicht aber sie ist nach außen
gerichtet sie es auf einen empfang
gerichtet der innenraum dient etwas ganz
anderem
und jetzt lautet die these dass dieses
ganz andere
also die aufspaltung in inneres und
äußeres eine faltung sei eine falte
zwischen innen und außen sowie die
perücken maskerade und der der innere
seelenzustand des menschen eine
entfaltung ins äußere und ins innere sei
und der witz dieser interpretation ist
nun zu sagen dass das ding um das es da
geht die kirche der mensch oder was auch
immer nicht etwas ist was jenseits
dieser haltung ist sondern was sich als
eine solche sich aus differenzierende
entfaltung verwirklicht das ganze nimmt
ja bezug dieses buch von jean de luz
1988 erschienen auf leibnitz mona
theologie eine der kompliziertesten
philosophie überhaupt die sehr sehr
schwer zu verstehen ist diese kleinen
monaten die eben auch keine fenster
keine türen haben in sich selber
faltungen darstellen wenn ihr die
monologen man auch weglassen und noch
über etwas anderes sprechen in der
philosophie interessant ist ja auch das
in die naturwissenschaften bauen brechen
der dinge passieren
16 33 steht galileo galilei vor dem
gericht muss sich verteidigen für sein
neues weltbild das er programmiert 50
jahre später erfindet newton oder
entdeckte newton die gravitationsgesetz
also bahnbrechende dinge reagiert die
philosophie darauf in verschiedener
hinsicht also galilei
ich kann ja auch als ein philosoph
betrachtet werden und nicht nur als als
ich diese trennung zwischen
naturwissenschaft und philosophie wie es
sie heute haben kann man für die
damalige zeit so gar nicht machen
jetzt bewegen wir uns natürlich weg von
der ersten fragestellung was ist
barockes denken da hatte sie löst diese
antwort ein entfalten sich bewegendes
denken hin zu der frage was sind
eigentlich die philosophien der zeit die
wir bei rock nennen
und da würde ich doch sagen dass die von
ihnen erwähnten jetzt
naturwissenschaftlichen entdeckungen vor
allem zu tun haben mit einer
mathematisierung der welt
das heißt dass man die welt und die
natur haben nicht nur die natur aber vor
allem die natur mit mathematischen
mitteln versucht zu konstruieren und
versucht über diese mathematisierung zu
erklären
zum beispiel in der natur bedeutet dass
natur gegenstände sind über die
räumliche ausdehnung zu begreifen
sie sind im grunde biometrische
gegenstände diese traube zum beispiel
lässt sich begreifen als ein eine
bestimmte geometrische figur und aus
dieser geometrischen größe heraus
erklären und nicht aus irgendwelchen
anderen qualitäten und interessant ist
ja auch dass die philosophen die wir
auch aus besuchen kennen eben fast alle
auch aus mathematiker tätig waren also
nicht nur die naturwissenschaftler auch
philosophen waren sondern leite nichts
beispielsweise gilt aus der entdecker
erfinder der differenzial und
integralrechnung wieder ganz mathematik
wie sie wahrscheinlich studiert haben
ihn einreden
ich denke auch sehr wahrscheinlich beim
gleichen mathematiklehrer am eingang
meinem partner hieronymus nein der pater
lorenz machte kenne ich auch ja also da
war bei mir auf durchzug
das hat meine intelligenz bei weitem
überstiegen die zur unteren spannung
einer traube beispielsweise hätten wir
wahrscheinlich jetzt damit eben die
berechnen aber lassen wir das
mathematisierung des denkens das trifft
ja auch auf die musik zu also
beispielsweise hat einen ganz starken
hang zur saal zahlensymbolik viele dinge
lassen sich fast mathematisch
aufschlüsseln ja generell ist zu sagen
die rationalisierung also von
gegenständen das hat man in der musik in
barockzeit auch gesucht man suchte
formeln zu finden die dann einen
bestimmten effekt vermitteln diese
effekten lehre die dann eben diese das
prinzip der figuren lehrer eigentlich
zuhilfenahme neben gewisse figuren zu
finden die einen gewissen effekt dann
auslöst beim zuhören und natürlich
johann sebastian bach seine oberste
maxime war eigentlich die der klangrede
also dass man die rhetorik ganz eng an
die musik an koppelt das war eigentlich
eine oberste maxime uns alle sein
einen tollen werke hatte diesem prinzip
unterstellt und damit zusammen hängt
natürlich auch dann die zahlensymbolik
die wir alle kennen also ist das vom
formaufbau bis spielereien mit
verschiedenen zahlen versteckte zahlen
das ist alles sehr spannend gibt ja auch
viele stücke von ihnen denen er dient
die noten entsprechenden
anfangsbuchstaben oder den buchstaben
seines namens ja genau das hatte
mehrmals verwendet auch bgh ja das ist
auch eine form von spielerei zum teil
versteckt zum teil offensichtlich
gesetzt erhältlich eine frage dazu diese
sogenannte figuren lehrer also das ist
jetzt der gedanke dass bestimmte
festgelegte klang figuren ein bestimmtes
gefühl vermitteln können
wie sehen sie das denn eigentlich es
gibt doch behauptungen dass das nur für
einen teil der musik gegolten hat von
dem ich die deutsche musik bis hin zu
bach führte da würden sie sagen das gilt
für die gesamte ich denke schon dass es
für die gesamte zeit sehr prägend war ja
so was wie die sehnsucht nach ordnung im
chaos
kann man das so sagen weil ich auch
diese üppigkeit ich finde das schwierig
zusammen zu bringen wenn man sich
überlegt dieses strenge mathematische
und gleichzeitig man die kirche ja und
sieht oder wir haben da einen einen
einen engel
das hat ja nichts streng mathematisch
ist sondern dass es ziemlich kite das
ist glaube dass gerade der reiz daran
oder eben verbindung ja ordnung im chaos
also es ist genau der reiz dieser
sinnlichkeit mit der ordnung zu
verbinden
das ist schon sehr extrem schauen wir
uns auch da noch ein beispiel an eines
solchen einem mathematischer versuch
fast schon mit musik umzugehen
bach ist auch berühmt dafür dass er so
genannte krebs kann ohne geschrieben hat
also kanone gesehen ein beispiel aus dem
musikalischen opfer und hören dass auch
das ist ein musikstück das sich von
vorne spielen lässt aber auch von hinten
spielen lässt und es tönt fliegt zweimal
genau gleich
ja es klingt gleich ob man es von vorne
spielt oder von hinten
[Musik]
das braucht ja also stelle ich mir vor
eine unglaubliche denkleistung sowas
komponieren zu können wie kriegt man
sowas hin
ist das nicht ein wenig schwierig ja ich
denke schon auch ja ich meine johann
sebastian bach ein genie und der hatte
das wahrscheinlich sehr schnell
hingeschrieben gegensatz zu selbst im
gefüge der dann auch noch kommt wieder
von vorne
genau wobei her das nicht so geschrieben
hat er hat nur eine linie geschrieben
dass das thema genommen eben das
berühmte erweitert und dann unten den
sopranos umgekehrt und ein zeichen
gesetzt und somit gesagt man sollte das
sofort auch von hinten nach vorne
spielen und kombinieren was wir hier
hören sind leichte zusammenklang das ist
ein so genannter krebs kolonie gehen das
ebenso funktioniert diese melodie kommt
ihnen auch noch toll tauchern mit
sicherheit sehr bekannt vor
weil es nämlich sozusagen der anlass ist
eines spielfilms indem sie eine ganz
wichtige rolle gespielt haben der film
heißt mein name ist bach heißt von
dominique de rivaz einer schweizer
regisseurin und dieser film erzählt die
entstehungsgeschichte dieser melodie
nämlich aus johann sebastian bach
eingeladen wurde von friedrich dem
zweiten den könig von preußen damals an
seinen hof und dort musste er diese
melodie komponieren
wir schauen uns gemeinsam einen
ausschnitt an aus diesem film indem ihr
sie auch er in ihrer rolle sehen ja
kompliment prinzessin
sehen sie buxtehude monte werden emanuel
bach werke die für mich herum liegen ist
er hat keinerlei respekt
ich sammle sie wie sie franz 11 legen
sie noch dieses hier
daran hänge ich am meisten bruder manuel
hatten sogar eine widmung
hineingeschrieben
manebach für die kunst die klaviatur zu
berühren
mit dem daumen zu spielen darauf muss
man bekommen wie kommt man überhaupt
ohne daumen spielen ich bin nur
friedemann bach
ich bin nicht hinsehen
wollen sie mit mir spielen
[Musik]
er verführt hier eigentlich wen hertha
mann
ich möchte dazu noch sagen der film der
erdachten schweizer filmpreis gewonnen
vor zehn jahren oder elf jahren
2003/2004 finden sehr gut gelungen sehr
mutiger film
sie verführt mich eindeutige geschichte
können sie denn eigentlich klavier
spielen oder haben sie das tier nur so
gut hingekriegt es zu spielen also in
diesem stück wurden wir gedoubelt beide
es gab es gibt eine andere szene wo ich
darauf bestanden habe dass ich das
selber spiele
das heißt ich bin selber klavier nein
aber ich habe es dieses kleine stück
akribisch drei monate geübt
mit einem ganz bekannten herrn der auch
in filmen wie farinelli oder rhodos der
könig tanzt musikalisch mitgeholfen hat
daniel lipnik aus belgien sehr bekannter
fahrer man mit dieser zeit mit dieser
musik und ich hatte meinem hotelzimmer
ein cembalo ein harziger und habe darum
geklemmt wird ja ich bin hier friedemann
bauch eben einen der bach söhne und
jetzt in versailles wieder die
barockzeit ist es schwierig sich als
schauspieler in die zeit hinein zu
versetzen
es ist herrlich dass ich in so eine zeit
hinein zu versetzen
man muss dazu auch wie schwierig ist es
ist braucht man muss das halt mit haut
und haar machen sowieso in dem künstler
werden für den künstler beruf lebt egal
ob musik oder maler oder autor
das macht man mit haut und haar mit
leidenschaft und mit seele und runter
und das gute setzt bei versailles die
sogar noch die ihm sogar noch mehr
dokumentierte zeit dass der zweite
weltkrieg
es gibt da kann man aus unermesslichem
fundus schöpfen und wie bereiten sie
sich denn vor so vorhin haben sie gesagt
barockmusik hilft ihnen beispielsweise
sich in solche rollen hinein zu denken
lesen sie da auch in welche
dokumentation historische bücher in die
epoche zu verstehen ja also ich sehe das
immer so dass schauspieler reise auch
ein bisschen was wie architektur also
ein architektenhaus und ich bau ne rolle
und wird diese rolle habe ich wie
architekt auch mehrere pläne einplanen
haupt plan ist das drehbuch und dann
gibt es ein anderer plan ist gespräche
mit meinem regisseur sekundärliteratur
filme dokumentationen musik und das ist
halt ab und dann irgendwann mal kommt
das alles zusammen und im idealfall
trägt man dann anfangen der dreharbeiten
in dieses haus rein ein dass man gebaut
hat und bewohnt das so authentisch wie
möglich in den gegebenen umständen gibt
es in die falten
wir halten das entspricht mir sehe ich
habe mich dass ihr damit identifizieren
mit diesem denken
erkennen sie müssen sich auch in rollen
reindenken ja ja also ich finde das ein
ganz tolles bild ja ich habe ein anderes
bild weniger gut das ist immer ich bin
schwanger
ich bin neun monate schwanger mit mit
dem mit dem werk in der zeit und
versuche mit allen sinnen die
geburtsstunde dann super hinzukriegen
und zu verstehen was jetzt abgeht und
das ist schon ich habe auch sehr
intensiv
ich glaube der unterschied ist aber dass
deine dass ihre ausführung
entschuldigung für diesen wirklich also
inzwischen haben sie gemacht haben
aber ich dass wir sie haben dann
meistens denke ich eine aufführung auf
die sich schon mal handel und bei mir
ist jetzt wie zb bei werk sei das sind
zehn folgen da gehen die dreharbeiten
von user von von mitte august bis anfang
märz
und so darum ist es eine lange geburt
sozusagen habe ich finde ihr bild auch
sehr schön ja wahrscheinlich genau
gleich es geht uns leid geht um es
gleich er genau noch ein kleiner hinweis
zu bach intern so zu sagen es gibt die
these dass gar nicht johann sebastian
bach alle diese musik geschrieben hat
sondern eigentlich vor allem seine frau
anna magdalena das behauptet ein
musikwissenschaftler martin jarvis und
im anschluss an die sendung zeigen wir
den film hätten bei miesbach die in
dieser film zeigt eben genau diese these
verdichtet diese these
die ist einfach ein kleiner hinweis aber
jetzt zurück zu dieser geschichte mit
dem barock oder zu dieser geschichte der
sich verbreiten ist auch das spielt ja
eine ganz ganz große rolle staffage
kostüme wie man sich kleidet und wenn
ich mir überlege was im moment
eigentlich bei ihnen jetzt für uns von
außen gesehen aktuell ist dann ist es ja
was ganz anderes nämlich die wikinger
sage also noch mehr läuft im moment bei
uns in den kinos an
da tragen sie ja ganz was anderes
nämlich so eine unglaubliche rüstung was
ich denn bequemer die jugend perücke
oder diese wikinger rister juckende
perücke und ja also wobei das kann man
nicht sagen bequemer weil man muss ja
auch
man umarmt seine rolle man muss ihn
lieben man muss sie verstehen
und da ist das jucken das gehört
natürlich da auch dazu weil im
siebzehnten jahrhundert gab es keinen
kein condition und kein shampoo und so
das ist auch okay wenn es juckt oder
jetzt bei wikinger film 16 kilogramm
rüstung
und dann eben mal auf zum beispiel aufs
klo gehen mussten ja auch die wicklung
aufs klo gehen die haben das erscheinen
die hose gemacht
wir haben das nicht gemacht das gehört
aber auch dazu dass das ist so ein
das spürt man auch nicht ja und man
sollte auch nicht klagen oder sich
beklagen drüber aber wenn sie mich so
fragen dann ist mir von der zeit her das
siebzehnte jahrhunderte spätbarock zeit
wo werk spielt lieber als das neunte
jahrhundert und land ja es gibt ja viele
historiendrama im kino das ist etwas was
die menschen fasziniert warum
interessieren jungs für solche stoffe
nicht natürlich falsche auskommen
[Musik]
ich kann jetzt nur darüber spekulieren
wir können mal auf den barock selber
beziehen jetzt nicht auf die wikinger
sondern auch mehr offen und also über
uns selber nachdenken warum sitzen wir
hier und warum interessieren sich so
viele dafür da gibt es hier gibt es
vielleicht mehrere möglichkeiten also
auf der einen seite so eine bedeutung
wie diese falte sie haben es ja eben
unmittelbar angesprochen wie gesagt dass
das sich unmittelbar anspricht
das ist ja ist ja eine form des denkens
die möglicherweise auf differenz abzielt
und das ist ja etwas was in unserer
jetzt zeit eine große rolle spielt sich
ausdifferenzieren differenzen zur
entfaltung zu bringen das könnte etwas
sein was leute anspricht
ich selber entwerfen sich selber werden
authentizität oder was meinen sie
neulich haben in ferschweiler
tatsächlich das differente zuzulassen
also nicht sein ich da ganz verschiedene
lebensformen ganz verschiedene
lebensformen an sich selber sich mit
meister wie sagt man sich neu erfinden
und all diese dinge wenn man das jetzt
mal weniger platt formuliert könnte man
natürlich sagen das sind lauter
faltenwürfe eines individuums ja und
dann könnte man sagen das ist etwas was
die gegenwart ansprechen könnte man kann
aber auch ein bisschen ideologie
kritischer ran gehen und sagen
vielleicht bringt das auch ganz andere
dinge die
leute zur identifikation da bewegen zum
beispiel die machtdemonstration des
absolutismus ist ja auch was tolles sich
da macht zu unterwerfen und zudem ein
heim zu geben und etwas entlasten ist
das könnte man problematischer sehe
nicht dass man das eine
identifikationsfigur ist und zu mal wenn
die macht dann auch noch mit solcher
sinnlichkeit einhergeht
dann ist sie gleich 6 ich glaube
allgemeinen verkleiden und der mensch
versucht sich zu begreifen zu verstehen
zu erklären und das wird sich hinten
verschob sich zu verkleiden und
vielleicht auch eine andere rolle zu
spielen ob das jetzt im karneval ist
oder da oder in beiden tat finden
verkleidet man sich auch beim militär
verbreitet man sich auch 1 1 1 1
street parade oder zum beispiel schon
stuhl des oder pilot ja das waren damals
in den 50er 60er an land das helden
haben sich alle köpfe gedreht wurden da
irgendwie da ist vielleicht jetzt zum
zürcher flughafen nicht aber damals oder
auch das hat noch irgendwie was so ja
noch so eine bewunderung und spüren und
was neues erleben und so und darum ist
glaube ich auch die wikinger zeit hat er
das ist eine zeit die ist uns vielleicht
noch mehr als die ägypter und die
mesopotamien und die griechen weil sie
doch noch ein paar jahrhunderte später
ist aber als diese wikingerzeit jetzt zu
dieser film spielt muss man bei king
sager über die hat noch nicht zu viel
erzählt da gibt es aber neben diesen
ausstellungen gerade in berlin in den
gropius gebäuden die aus england kam
hochspannend hoch faszinierend sagt aber
auch alles was damit zu tun ein bisschen
den menschen zu verstehen um zu
begreifen sein vielleicht weiß ich nicht
eine faszination die zu tun haben könnte
beim barock oder etwas was uns auch sehr
ansieht ist wahrscheinlich auch diese
sinnlichkeit der barock ist üppiger ist
aber auch sehr sinnliches steckt
eigentlich voller erotik historisch
gesehen oder ideengeschichtlich gesehen
ist da diese diese zeit gegen geht nicht
ein in der die effekt lehre auch
entsteht was ist genau da vergeht
das ist etwas finde ich was wir mit dem
zu tun hat was sie vorher in bezug auf
die figuren lehre erwähnt haben effekte
also wir würden heute sagen emotionen
oder gefühle da verschiedene andere
ausdrücke könnte man dafür einsetzen
effekte sind ja etwas was uns widerfährt
also wir wenn wir angst haben wenn wir
freude verspüren wenn wir zur und
verspüren das ist etwas was uns über
kommt das hat man also bedeutet als
wieder fans ja und dann ist das problem
wenn wir wenn wir als eine affekt natur
solchen widerfahren essen ausgeliefert
sind
wie können wir eigentlich stabil unser
leben führen man braucht also eine form
von nennen wir es mal rationalisierung
dieser wieder fans und umgangs
möglichkeiten mit diesen widerfahren ist
und die effekten lehre soll so etwas
bieten
sie versucht die effekte zu erklären
jetzt verschiedene möglichkeiten wie man
das machen
grund effekte zu bilden mittels deren
mann die anderen effekte ordnet und dann
versucht man zu zeigen wie man mit
diesen begriffen den effekten umzugehen
vermag ich so was die stressbewältigung
moderne aufklärer oder ja ich würde weiß
nicht ob vielleicht kann man stress auch
als einen affekt bezeichnen also es
kommt es weniger es ist schon auch eine
technik aber es ist weniger eine technik
wie wir jetzt die stressbewältigung es
ist schon ein erst man kann sagen es ist
ein therapeutisches anliegen ja es
sollen bestimmte effekte aufgelöst
werden beziehungsweise ich sage lieber
mit ihnen umgegangen werden bewältigt
werden
in der musik scheint mir das ist eine
these der musikwissenschaftlerin silke
leopold scheint mir zum beispiel die da
capo arie in der in der barockoper eine
klare effekt bewältigung sari und ein
effekt rationalisierungs arie
also diese das ist so eine dreiteilige
form
und in der mitte rast der effekt los
zornes alle waren sind arien und so
weiter und dann können wir das aber
wieder eingebunden durch diese strenge
dreiteilige formen das ist ein umgang
mit einem effekt also wir haben aber das
ist weder capo also ein teil
und dann gibt's den mittelteil dann gibt
es ein teil haben nochmals nochmal
verfahren eine art wiederholungen und
dadurch wird der effekt eingebunden und
gleichzeitig kann dann aber raus kommen
ja er kann sich darstellen er kann ins
äußere sich entfalten wenn man jetzt
diese dieses bild wieder nehmen möchte
ein motiv was in der musik ja auch
vorkommt im spätbarock beginnt dieses so
genannte motiv erkennen können sie uns
mal ein seufzer motiv zeigen ja also es
sind eigentlich sekunden springer
meistens aufwärts wobei dann immer bei
den zwei zb achtel bewegung immer die
erste note betont wird und von daher
kommt dieses seufzen oder dieser
abstecher in die geschichte die dann
diesen effekt auslöst
das ist das also darin eingebunden in
der musik des barock ja das wurde sehr
oft verwendet das ist auch eines der
berühmtesten effekte diese figur des
ostens und gerade musikalischen opfer
kommt das ja ganz deutlich und mehrfach
vor beim letzten teil dieses trio sonate
diebach geschrieben hat da das quillt
und perlt andauernd von diesen mit
diesen motiven
wenn wir über diese ganze effekt theorie
nachdenken ein bisschen plastischer
werden dann ist man bei leben in der
musik auch bei der frage warum hatte man
eigentlich so mir sehnsucht nach diesen
engelsstimmen also stichwort die
kastraten die ja unglaubliche stars
ihrer zeit waren sie selber haben früh
in dem film farinelli erwähnte das
schicksal erzählt der figur farinelli an
einem berühmtesten kastraten jener zeit
und heute hat man ja keine kastraten
mehr gott sei dank nicht mehr es wurde
ihnen verboten sondern heute werden
diese stimmen gesungen von
countertenören
sie sind ein countertenor und sind
bereit uns etwas vorzusingen erkennen
und zwar sähen sie uns aus der händel
oper rinaldo die arie cara sposa und die
hören wir uns jetzt sehr sehr gerne an
wie das links daneben ein countertenor
finden
[Musik]
o
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie machen sie das ganz toll
also hat er macht das ganz toll
amerikanerin riedemann so das ist in der
natur gegeben also ich sehe ja mit der
falsettstimme bisher sind die fahrgäste
und das hat jedermann und polizisten von
dem man ja immer spricht das können alle
männer die einfach mit der hohen stimme
singen
und was hat er einfach mit der hohen
stimme sind sie die kopfstimme oder ja
aber dieser begriff kopfstimme versetzt
stimme das ist ja ein disput der schon
mehrere hundert jahre geht es ist ein
begriffs problem für mich ist falls
register nicht gleich kopf register es
ist ein ganz fassen sind vielleicht kann
ich das mit einem bild darstellen wenn
sie von der garagen zu hause vielleicht
ein in den siebten stock möchten
erfahren möchten dann fahren sie mit dem
lift hoch bis zum fünften stock müssen
aber dann umsteigen in einen anderen
lief der fährt die dann in den siebten
stock und dann haben sie himmelhoch
jauchzende schöner aussicht künftig
statt das heißt es gibt keine verbindung
zwischen bruststimme und sehr hoher
falsett register das ist ein bruch
einbruch dem in der j-league zum
beispiel super perfekt ausnutzen muss
damit dieser ihn runter kommt ich kann
eigentlich überhaupt nicht die rodel
nein ich bin keine oder aber ich kann es
vielleicht ganz gut vor machen als er
macht das mit der bruststimme und kippt
dann in dieses falls add hoch das ist
das gleiche wie wenn sie eben wenn es im
siebten stock möchten andauernd diesen
lift wechseln um spaß haben daran so
haben die jodler spaß mit diesem kit das
ist die serie und das ist die hohe
stimme mit plus stimme unten und das
sehr vereinfachte so darzustellen
diese hohe stimme die haben auch diese
herren
auch irgendwo in sich drin aber es
stimmt ja also ich weiß jetzt nicht
genau das ist schlussendlich ist es
training einfach oder üben training
haben wir die noch irgendwo du viele als
sie vielleicht also die also direkt sie
sind vorhanden und man hat es gespürt
dass zu bringen oder nicht und wenn man
es natürlich dann kunstvoll einsetzen
möchte braucht das schon ein training
und früher hat man das sozusagen anders
hergestellt diese stimme in dem man die
männer aus knaben behalten hat sozusagen
durch die kastration hat man verhindert
dass der stimmbruch einsetzt
dadurch hatten die männer zwar große
brust körper also viel volumen aber sie
hatten immer noch eigentlich die stimme
einer frau richtig ja das ist ein sehr
spezielles da auch dunkles kapitel wenn
man denkt wie viele knaben kassiert
worden sind und der klang war aber doch
ziemlich anders gegenüber den fazit ist
also ein countertenören eben gerade aus
diesem grund weil sie ja nicht mit dem
vz weg ist das singen sondern mit der
brust und kopf stimme und das ist ein
ganz anderer klang an knaben klang
klingt anders als eben nur wenn man mit
der faz stimme passiert register sind
weiß man dass der raum meinen dass ihnen
die so zu herzen geht also von farinelli
weist man was die frauen reihenweise in
ohnmacht gefallen sind als er zu singen
begonnen hat und das war ja nicht nur
weil der mann als besonders schön war
sondern dass eine stimme es war wichtig
das singen und wenn sie jetzt wohin
gesungen haben dass er so eine
unmittelbarkeit die aus der stimme kommt
aber warum er spricht denn das anders an
die wenn eine frau mit einer normalen
als stille diese arien sievers krankheit
entrückt es klang als klang an die
andere gehen will man das immer sagen
möchte es klang einfach nicht irdisches
es ist irgendetwas dazwischen
und ja die katholische kirche hat er
selber gesagt dass der zugang zum himmel
gesang eigentlich nur geht über die
entrücktheit über den traum dann den man
irgendwie auch mitbekommt und so kommt
man zur himmlische musik und das war
sicher auch der grund weshalb dann
kastraten auch gesund haben dann in der
kirche unter anderem natürlich geht es
auch darum dass die frau nicht reden
durfte in der kirche aber und dadurch
auch nicht singen durfte und deshalb
diese situation entstand aber diese
entrücktheit ist wird man auch gesucht
und gerade farinelli der musste eine
ganz spezielle begabten gehabt haben
thöne sehr lange auszuhalten mit einem
messer sei das langsame dynamische
abends steigen will das team mal
zurücknehmen und dann diese endlosen
koloraturen der die er perfekt hatte und
schauen wir uns doch einen ausschnitt
aus diesen vielen
dann sehen wir das
[Musik]
ja es wie ein popstar der inszeniert ja
ja eine diva war und ich glaube auch ich
weiß nicht ob das stimmt dabei ich
glaube man hat ja die stimme synthetisch
hergestellt nicht und ich glaube ein
mann hat eine knabenstimme und eine
frauenstimme verschmolzen um diese
kastraten stimme zu imitieren
man hatte genau man hat diese stimme
zusammengelegt und im studio damit es
möglichst krass teil der stimmumfang war
dermassen gross der gerade auf farinelli
hatte das ist unmöglich zu
bewerkstelligen nur mit mit einer
counter mit einer von sechs stimmen wenn
jetzt diese sinnlichkeit sehen in diesem
theater dieser federschmuck diese stimme
und gleichzeitig am anfang haben wir
darüber gesprochen absolutismus
gotteslob also die die kirche ist extrem
dominant in dieser zeit bringen wir das
zusammen
das ist ja auch wenn für die denken
oftmals schwierig gewesen zusammen zu
bringen
also es gibt natürlich verschiedene
möglichkeiten was zusammen zu bringen
eine möglichkeit ist über den ordnungs
begriff zu arbeiten
wir hatten ja vorhin schon mal darüber
gesprochen dass in diesem chaos eine
bestimmte ordnung dennoch zu tage liegt
selbst in diesem ganzen gekräuselten des
innenraumes oder dieser säcke technik
auch und es gibt also eine ordnung wenn
man die raus findet dann kann man
natürlich auch über den ordnenden etwas
herausfinden also über gott letztlich
nur das wäre eine möglichkeit den
gottesbezug in diese sinnlichkeit
hineinzudenken
das müssen wir jetzt helfen die ordnung
also federschmuck diese stimme
wo war die ordnung das doch ja das ist
richtig aber die musik ist ja
organisiert denn sie ist ja jetzt nicht
so ausschweifend sie sich bewegt so
streng formal organisiert ist hier auch
sie ist ja nicht jetzt sich zum beispiel
viel geordneter als trieb musicals
mittleren neunzehnten jahrhunderts
wirklich sagen in vielen hinsichten
obwohl sie diesen diese dass wir jetzt
ja auch besonders stark sich diese
ausbrüche erlaubt das falten modell kann
da auch wieder weiterhelfen denn man
kann sagen all diese
gehäuse und all die sinnlichkeit und so
weiter sind entfaltungen und diese
entfaltung lassen sich auf bestimmte
regeln bringen die man möglicherweise
sogar bleibt jetzt dachte das berechnen
kann
ja also fonds kalkuliert mundes als gott
rechnete schufa die welt entstand die
welt also gott ist ein rechner
und jetzt man kann diese rechnung
versuchen nachzueifern das leibniz
gesagt die ganze zeit erst wenn gott als
gott rechnete entstand dem etwas ist was
wollen sie die schüler kommen sie aus
kalkulator rechnet fiat minus ab wie
sehen sie das sie haben mir auch erzählt
dass es ein gewisser hinsicht ja auch im
barock eben diese kirchenmusik gab aber
auf den sack geben auch die theaterwelt
entstanden ist
wie können wir die beiden dinge
zusammenbringen oder wissen sie gar
nicht zusammengebracht werden
die geistlichen ging ja glaub ich zum
teil auch ins theater oder ja
interessant ist ja diese dieser diskurs
von geistlich weltlich von macht der
musik im bezug zur liturgie das ist ja
der geschichte der kirche sehr
interessant und ausgerechnet oder
überhaupt in der barockzeit ging diese
spannung dieser diskurs eigentlich den
hintergrund trat in den hintergrund weil
die hatten einer gemeinsamen ebene das
ist das repräsentieren weltliche wie
geistliche fürsten ihre macht zu
repräsentieren
gerade in der gegenreformation als die
kirche natürlich werbung machen musste
propaganda denen sie ein propagandavideo
der verbreitung des glaubens das war ein
ganz ganz wichtige sache also hier
kommen kommt kommen diese beiden
elementen stark zusammen diese
barockzeit also man wieder sozusagen
gott feiern aber auch den fans feiern
deswegen sie dann schlossen diverser ja
zum teil auch fast aus wie eine kirche
wie es mit dem mit den gewändern wenn
wir noch einmal einfachen handy denken
dieser federschmuck
es gibt ja auch dieses sehr stark
weibliche dass es in diesen kostümen zu
tage trete in dem film mein name ist
bach haben sie keine kirche getragen
aber jetzt in der es ertragen sie
offenbar per regierungsstrukturen auch
stromlosen wie ist das was man sich so
weiblich zu verkleiden
nochmals das gehört einfach zur rolle
dazu das gehört zu dieser zeit dazu das
ist also der dresscode häufig oder nicht
höflich war einfach so war auch
vielschichtig es bringt natürlich auch
eine gewisse das hilft auch eine gewisse
körperlichkeit in die rolle
reinzubringen und man bewegt sich anders
was sie auch ganz wichtig ist weil an
diesen höfen war ja eine streng
geordnete etikette wie man sich
gegenüber trat oder dann vor allem als
laura reinkamen der könig reinkamen da
war ja ja ja ja also eine körperliche so
eine körperlichkeit es hilft auf jeden
fall diese zeit noch mehr zu bewohnen
oder noch mehr zu spüren oder noch mehr
zu leben nicht nur mit der perücke
sondern auch vor allem mit dem kostüm
sprechen diese etikette an manieren ganz
wichtig in dieser zeit auch der barocke
tarnt sich der eigentlich sehr statisch
sehr sehr stark reglementiert wenn man
da sieht man so kostümfilm denkt man
immer die kann sich ja kaum belegen weil
ich so aufrecht alles ist das werde ich
auch in dem bereich zumindest in den
umkreis dieser effekten bewältigung
rechnen also wenn sie sich mal
vorstellen wie wir heute affektiert
tanzen ja und wie geregelt dass damals
war wie geordnet das damals war und wie
trotzdem in dieser ordnung effekte zum
ausdruck gelangen konnten
dass glaube und gleichzeitig was ein
marktmechanismus nicht so lange getanzt
wurde konnte man nichts schlechtes tun
haben wir sozusagen beschäftigt ja mit
dem pferd mit dem zeremoniell und
gregory katz der war
der verliebt in die tänze dient diese
ordnung und in dieser aufstellung von
tänzen der war ja es gibt einen
wunderschönen französischen film das
leerrohr doms der könig tanzt der sich
vor allem auf dieses höfische etikette
auf diese tänze konzentriert den ich mir
jetzt auch vor ein paar wochen angeguckt
habe sie sind meisterwerke
vielleicht ist das auch einige
faszinationen am barock dass es eben
einerseits dieses schwülstige die
effekte die effekt ausdrücken zulässt
aber gleichzeitig die ordnung nicht ganz
verlässt das ihr also sozusagen geordnet
schließlich sein dürfen
könnte man das so auf diese formel
bringen ich würde sogar sagen dass
bestimmte formen des barocks oversize
ein paradebeispiel dafür denken sie an
den garten
also da ist klar dass es ja so
übergeordnet dass die ordnung klar die
oberhand hat und vor allem noch wenn ich
den herrn professor kurz unterbrechen
das ist natürlich nicht super aber der
ui cups hat den garten so ausgerichtet
dass war ihm ganz wichtig auch wo man
anfing zu gehen wo man diesen garten
trat dann wollte er haben dass wenn man
da ein klang geht das denn dort ein
springbrunnen kommt und wenn man da
entlang geht also da war auch eine ganz
klare ordnung abfolge wie man diesen
garten zu begehen hatte und was für
sensationen da einem entgegen kann ja
presse die gartenwege gartengestaltung
ist ziemlich interessant weil gerade
wenn man jetzt den unterschied zum
beispiel zu den englischen gärten also
etwas nach barocken ins auge fasst nicht
also plötzlich wurden die gärten aus
dieser ordnung befreit scheinbar befreit
und das wurde sollten sozusagen
landschaften wieder gewonnen werden und
das ging einher natürlich mit einer
neuen konzeption von letztlich auf
gentleman und bürgerlichkeit
hindeutenden selbstverständlich sein
wenn wir zum schluss noch auf vanitas
eingehen also die haben jetzt viel
gesprochen über den punkt über das gold
über das gelage wir haben nicht
gesprochen über die schäferstündchen
aber die kommen natürlich auch vor
dann könnte man ja sagen die vanitas die
begleitet ja diese ganze zeit also
dieses carpe diem
wo spielt die vanitas denn eine rolle
kommt die irgendwie vor in den opern
oder warum sagt man ihm an wie das motiv
ist ist wichtig geben wo hat man eben
auch ein totenschädel wenn man von
barock spricht bekommt das vor
das kommt eigentlich immer vor denke ich
entweder sehr versteckt oder sehr
offensichtlich gesetzt kirchenmusik ist
es dann klar in welche richtung das dann
liegt christ lagen todes banken zb oder
andere kantaten die bewusst bezug nimmt
zu der vanitas aber in der oper dann
immer diese nach geschmack am schluss
noch da liegt auch etwas zerbrechliches
drin und denke dass es war immer
irgendwie präsent kann sich im
beispielgebend ist und nach geschmack
oder was meinen sie damit die
unverändert und dann ja dass die equine
dass die der der happy das happy end das
wurde dann immer so mit einem bitteren
beigeschmack von im ablauf der
geschichte fast jeder oper kommt das ja
eigentlich vor im barock dies diesem
hochmut zum beispiel die eine
protagonistin hat und dann fällt aber es
kommt dann trotzdem am schluss noch so
ein festliches ende dazu aber
irgendetwas stimmt nicht mit dem und das
kommt ein faszinierter oper vor wobei
ich glaube das ist zeitlos sich über die
generation das zieht sich über die
jahrhunderte
ob das jetzt barockes oder das
spätbarocke an der rokoko der überall
oder das ist zeitlos diese lassen sich
dann einen menschen dazu aber man kann
ja vielleicht schon sagen dass im barock
der tod auch sehr präsent war wir denken
an den 30 jährigen
die antworten waren früher gestorben ist
da war die lebenserwartung eines
menschen war mit 40 maximal mitte 50
vielleicht das lag sehr eng beieinander
die medizin war alles andere als da gab
es noch kein penicillin also das gibt
zwei gründe warum ich nicht in der
barockzeit leben möchte dass eines
penicillin zweites toilettenpapier gab
es bei das licht oder das jetzt weil sie
vielleicht setzt sich gerade wieder zur
alten papieren position aber es hat doch
sicher auch herr leicht gibt es auch
andere gründe sind dies wahr ist ja ich
würde da auch unterscheiden wollen mit
dem bunny tas gedanken zwischen den
verschiedenen ausprägungen also die
lutherische kultur durch die am bach
sehr geprägt hatte sicherlich ein
anderes oder gruß in der literatur hatte
er sich ein anderes vanitas verständnis
als jetzt die er durch die
gegenreformation geprägte katholische
kultur das interessante glaube ich für
uns oder das faszinierende und
vielleicht auch im unterschied zu
anderen epochen auffallende ist dass es
das vanitas gerade in dieser möglichkeit
gesehen wurde
also dass in dem aufblühen das sterben
da ist oder das vergängliche
die dazu noch ein beispiel geben zum
schluss ihn aufbringen das sterben
also ich da ich habe gerade ein bild vor
erhalten was ich vor kurzem in new york
war in der trick collection gesehen habe
dummerweise weiß ich nicht mehr genau
den titeln das ist eine allegorische
darstellung dass kraft und weisheit die
welt regieren und kraft ist ein
muskulöser herr und weisheit ist eine
üppige frau und im hintergrund steht
ganz an das barnettas mann die tat um
es ist alles vergänglich also kraft und
weisheit so üppig und stark sie sind
letztlich ist die welt samstag
ein kleiner bruch noch wie sind am ende
unseres gesprächs ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich ein an herr hinrichs erkennen
dass sie zu uns gekommen sind dankeschön
auch ihnen danke ich für das interesse
mehr von den sternstunden geht's am
kommenden sonntag dann ist eva l
bei mir zu gast die renommierte
soziologin erforscht seit vielen jahren
unser liebesleben und sie erklärt
weshalb die liebe weh tut und warum sie
sich dennoch lohnt schalten sie zu
[Musik]